hey guys I'm Jesse welcome to our launch
day livestream for Middle Earth shadow
of war I have two special guests today
I'm joined by two members of the warp
zone Davis and Schroeder hey guys hello
hello so if you're confused because
you're watching on the warp zones
YouTube channel we are at GameSpot
they're here in San Francisco right now
but we're also streaming on GameSpot
GameSpot's YouTube GameSpot's twitch and
yeah your channel so yeah thanks for
joining we have done what you're not
supposed to do we just cross the streams
but it did not cause and we can do this
because of Duracell Thank You Duracell
for sponsoring the stream we are playing
on the Xbox one today and we're gonna
jump in right into the game so Davis is
gonna go first we're gonna take turns
for the next hour and a half playing
shadow catch people up this is what
happened what happened oh we made a ring
we made a ring and this is Talon and
then she loves still the ring because
she loves the lady in this one and not a
spider well she's kind of a spider too
and then the city is in season we got a
rescue the city and now ork action go
kill there killed Avis okay thank you
Oh who stole my kill it's called kill
securing oh yeah they can catch on fire
now which was weird she's like why are
they on why are some of them on fire
there's just a lot more fire yeah so
this is your first playthrough of shadow
before yeah yes and you guys play chat
of Mordor yeah very nice so were you
guys fans of the game oh yeah and what
were you hoping for for this game with
sieges know something bad it's like the
first trailer was just like okay I'm in
I did not know I I was all in when I saw
the first or first siege was like I feel
like ridiculous we're all in with just
the title announcement but okay yeah
we're all in again very nice very nice
double
I don't want term so we doubled down
there it is we double down on when I go
to Vegas I just watch people I don't
know so yeah we're not that far into the
game so if you're watching and confused
about where we are we're maybe what 13
30 minutes yeah not not far at all yeah
yeah we gotta think is still kind of
part of the tutorial stuff they're still
showing us how to do things
yeah still given us prompts guys are
super cool nice that is really cool yeah
look how fancy tallian is now yeah I
like the Reg it sort of he's got like a
like a Nova Corps thing going on
actually good stuff yeah okay can we
just trade jackets you can have mine I
don't know he's got the armor of the
Rangers yeah that's true it's a
collector's item yeah you may want to
leave that in a display case or
something you shouldn't be wearing
Italian so what did you like about the
first game just I really liked the
action oh I really liked love I really
liked leveling up your character to the
point of just being able to decimate and
i what i i'm liking right here is they
didn't like totally reset you back to
one you get to keep most of your moves
and stuff so that's yeah that's really
nice because yeah that would have been a
bummer to be like alright well now I can
only attack just to like New York's at a
time to create something to just like
had like one skill point yeah moves yeah
alright alright now we can secure the
city this is good I do need to pick up
the execution move that because yes it's
very useful that's what like the story
is awesome but when I was playing shadow
of Mordor I definitely just was like oh
now I'm gonna run off in this round
direction and like do all the cool stuff
we got Sauron he's got he's got mini
eyes now all right well
a solid plan secure the Palantir
complete diving objectives prevent the
penalty from falling instruments answer
all right let's do that
let's go complete those right alright so
yes we are hanging out in chat we're on
gamespot we're on youtube on both the
games my channel and the warp zone
channel and we're also on GameSpot's
switch so if you've got questions we may
have answers but it's a lot of chats
join the join all of them yes join in
that shed yeah you can jump that you can
jump that do it right yeah oh my
goodness oh there's a guy to interrogate
oh gosh no that's not a human general
you go right cool I think he ran away
you gotta go get it yeah they ran up
okay well up Oh fine upwards where'd he
go hey can they like run away it might
have pieced out
oh gee thanks whoops it's okay okay this
is how love works it's in pull-up Intel
over to the right yeah you're Chet
demon king 85 said what difficulty are
you playing on normal yeah normal normal
there we go there's a guy so what's that
got interrogate yeah great bumper
this guy who's got legs what is
happening yep and he can climb anything
vault vault Volvo Oh to get your speed
boosts there you go speed booze no hey
ASB booze are you going why is everyone
so fast
hey over vs. oh you have to have to leap
over that stop jerk so you don't I don't
have it mastered yet alright so shoot at
him someone suggest in the chat no oh
well a horse shaman week yep so you're
gonna run across a bunch of different
captains if you interrogate arrows you
can find out what their weaknesses are
oh gosh okay so I can't shoot him and
he's tough to kill with this have to
kill right you're gonna do great what's
gonna be fine what is the worst that
could happen it's going to be fun
and the other guys on arrow proof okay
[Laughter]
all right I get why people watching I
will handle it in a sec a lot of stuff
happening more guys are coming you just
gotta take them out this I know I don't
have an execute yet though just use
counter ticking
there you go
ooh I got it you're a cursed and you're
dead Oh No
be sure to don't miss that why don't
miss the why okay why avoid the enemy
attacks to recover you got it no you got
it you're losing health you've got it
like run away
you got a counter there now you're
uncurse adapted I'm gonna do this thing
where I find someone attached he'll
retreat find some guy by himself and
just go up the wall oh right now I can't
climb everything I think you can okay oh
[Laughter]
you're still unlocking stuff if you guys
are drinking Middle Earth shadow war on
oh thank you here we go now yeah most
now go back huh go back
but you know you can also drink again
oh right bumper right bumper right
bumper and be
okay this little guy alive oh oh
rekt and you're on fire don't kill him
[Laughter]
okay the last guy who's your orcs all
right well you better drain him good
grab him
yeah you can just do beat yeah yeah and
his head explodes Oh a life gem that
sounds like a thing that I could you
know that is still on I haven't lost it
yet yeah that good old shadow a battle
what's called shadow of war this is war
and hold a double mark all right
all right you got it okay just put that
gem in there doesn't bonuses okay it's
does health stone oh I saw cool that's
cool
great great let's all right let's go
steel help okay guys full almost full
help maybe drain this guy to use the
Force yes all right oh hell so now
there's three three guys to interrogate
northeast you're gonna be fine you got
this ye of little faith I just said
you're going to be fine
did you hear sarcasm in my voice I felt
it I don't know I don't know what you're
talking about
dude let's play this cool there's a guy
there's a pole refuted that by himself
but it'll look cool the string in stream
want me to there you go can you Adam
welcome how do you tell you her husband
he's got some hops oh there's a guy
alright easy out easy out he's already
running like they have kind of the same
Lawson alright things about some people
where I already know this guy yeah ii
choose a different captain look at
unknown captain sure they've got he's
got a connection yeah sorry yeah makuu
of the i learn about him okay leads a
group of warriors okay warriors oh gosh
she's got a lot of stuff
what's the bleakest uh-oh where's the
weakness enraged by spiders oh did you
want to get stuck oh boo okay so you got
to sneak up on him does it say wouldn't
you haven't seen him yet so he's still
both can be killed instantly using
poison
said it Oh image by executions
explosions of peace all right this guy's
easy out except for rat bang that guy's
my boy no we haven't seen that bag all
right
also I think I thought you were holding
with your hands I'm like you are gonna
get nose ropers yeah nice job practicing
on that on that pillar
bye right in the gut
and then you go oh alright
hey buddy back you were wrote SK
[Laughter]
dude and step yeah Middle Earth shadow
of war the sequel to shadow of Mordor
and we are playing on the Xbox one
brought to you by Duracell the just
Branford's bucks gamers and we're
switching off for the next hour and a
half
playing on single mode new dagger OH
Rangers dagger okay so I'm gonna give up
my son help train him with yeah maybe he
doesn't look so what's new with longing
that's the gym oh I think you there yeah
oh yeah that that's the way wait for it
yeah cuz then I can when I give enough
others that's killer on a fire I can
like incident execute people in combat
and I won't have such a chump
[Laughter]
don't kill that's the guy's just like oh
wait oh nut self kill exploded into my
eyeball the fire yes
yeah yeah looks great yeah it looks
great it looks like just a swift kick in
the face okay let's be honest there are
times where kicking is warranted I'm not
gonna get into all of them but generally
don't kick people along this life for a
few more seconds all right all right
just guys can you just let me kill you
haha how many wasn't even nice next oh
it wasn't even merciful he's just like
you know wait please press right here
oh oh wait oh shoot okay I got another
job very nice
I've got a question about multiplayer in
this game yes there is the game's
multiplayer features a social conquest
mode and that's where players are able
to invade other players fortresses and
attempt to conquer them that mode has
two settings friendly and ranked so
friendly allows the player to invade
someone's fortress without the risk of
losing an army and rank on the other
hand allows the players invade but with
the risk of losing some of your orphans
Roman Italy so there's that I will be
playing the friendly yeah does that mean
it means there's probably gonna be a
bomb usually a red thing means an
explosion yeah there are barrels you
know
thank you thank you my heightened
reflexes allowed me to make it seem as
though time slowed down okay I know
you're on my team guys guys don't do
that I'm Way too close
archers felt that one when I can hear
whizzed by like a nerf I'm not cool all
I want is to execute people
no it's like maybe you should do one
mission okay can do that one yep just
follow the marker this is C but you can
literally define just everything so you
just get across without even okay Oh
screaming all right I'm gonna play the
game then like run over here - Marill
whoo that jump is ridiculous
super jump up just from here all the way
yeah pretty much
are these hydeia about documentation of
the Milan tier well we can turn starting
to lose colors can give us sight
we will purify them and make them yeah
yes smash it Oh with your
whoa cool lost secrets all right again
the surrounding area to find it Hydra
colder Oh with him here we go
I don't know we found something keep
going keep scanning oh okay there's a
memory you keep going
you've gone they're gonna be so many
markers on this map oh okay in the
person you didn't just tell you where it
was here he's kind of fine then I will
show you came now we must retrieve also
working barrel for all those hey Kat
what's the bear over on our twitch chat
group she riot hey goob he said how far
is the game as this we're probably about
40 minutes in yeah this is 40 minutes of
story oh yeah we've been maybe in terms
of story 20 minutes like the opening
cutscenes yeah wow he's engaged in
combat it's like stealth kill count it
ooh treasure guys there's a guy open up
[Laughter]
we got
is it a better life do I like it I like
it
who is this guy that's just always there
is he like our main target
of what we have it set on right now am I
going to the right place you're going to
a place looks like it's on your map so
you can check out your map worse than
that I think that's the other button the
other button here back in Lublin you
there it is okay look at all those
markers that's part of the mappers the
blue on us that's what you're going to
yes I think hover over it you'll see
what do I want to cleanse all of these
or go do the person or you know it's an
open world you can do whatever you want
I'm not lazy I'm not just gonna be right
here shadows of the past discover
Caliburn bores ancient storehouse and
explore the memories of his past
struggles with Sauron alright
elven rage I don't know kind of like do
I go down here oh so it's a location
okay check the old map before just jump
in the water no you go right there it's
a it's a cave oh now we know what a
barrows is yeah barrows is just a caves
like yes there it is okay that's fine
you could have just called like a your
pardon barrows trolls you call them cave
trolls I know you have the word press
left over to enter race world and to
find
nope that's fire the only thing that I
don't think you're going though alright
maybe maybe towards the Waypoint all
right jerk
ooh hey oh whoa
there we go it's kind of cool
you bet it on a dead battles like this
one oh okay there just what is reserved
yeah protected with anti fortune army
always you still have here we go be sure
to block protect yourself I didn't get
through all this stuff in the first game
did our Sauron and Killebrew more like
they were buddies never Type O then
Sauron left a mean whoa here you go you
do get to press Y a lot oh yeah three
elements press tap X repeatedly to kill
grunt orcs aim at captain's with X deal
massive damage soon great let's do that
you want to know cal aborts caleb
reports ready crater he's always owe
your forgiveness though their friend
orcs swing and hope for the best
you might have killed a few of your
allies get that race game it's just
killing it needs to get frickin yeah the
word race is used a lot in this race so
I'm not gonna hold that against okay we
have boom
it's got cooler overnight - Raj
I think it's that's the blue meter I
don't know you had a 33 Street there for
a while though those but they are
impressive
Oh
get there get there all right do it
both exit go go go kill people use it on
people Oh
this real I think we're gonna get this
now did you do this yeah memory damn
dude okay yeah that's hubris he's like
that magnet I put in my gauntlet oh yes
that's gonna end well and we're back
it's gonna end very well did you have
you know okay so we can't pull down so
how are you feeling so we we're a half
hour into the stream do you want to
switch off are you feeling good you want
to go over all right good effort good
job you did it after the stream is over
I get this room alone for like six hours
right yeah yes you take out as many
words as you can what so now we have
shredder taking over if you're just
tuning in very nice that was good go
good spots and Don that's fun for you
okay all right now we're continuing on
with Schroeder we got here really the
history of the first war border yeah
children boy in the dark like Oh some
more cows bats here alright that's cool
yeah those are cool yeah writing is lost
for now so know you've got questions for
Davis you know they he's not playing go
ahead and asked in the chat we're over
on the warp zones YouTube we're on
GameSpot's YouTube games bus twitch and
gamespot.com I'm going to upgrade Brock
said is this full game or not this is
the full game we are playing the full
game on launch day
where was that execution move at the top
comment
yeah yeah yes okay just so you know
GameChanger
not fair really cool super thing I did
yeah that the game definitely didn't
help me do okay new enemy use your bow
ah yeah this would be interesting
because you don't have do you have the
ability to team over yet I don't know
probably not here goes I'm gonna into
which said can we put the skill to you
when there's a chance did you just do
that yeah it's like a skill flowchart
now pretty much oh there we go
I'm sorry sorry I would have written you
but it wasn't what they want yeah sorry
sorry dude who won see the skill tree
good wanted to see the sculpture
character character yes that stuff a lot
going on here yeah yeah instead of
columns it's now just it's rows they
also do you think of that change I like
it yeah um I feel like there's a lot
more going on well because before skill
trees would you could like advance
they're going downwards but sometimes
there would be just separate skills in
the same column that had nothing to do
with it here you can see like you can
get the skill and then there's three
unlocks or skill to upgrade it which is
exciting
oh that's cool shadow strike into a fire
pit what deaden hit it you just like
smoke bomb that's cool well anyway
alright yeah alright oh let's go to the
next day where's
so what are you heading for ah the next
Waypoint nice-looking what's ours purify
their volunteers Oh came out of nowhere
okay okay all right you wanna he is
pissed successful tax gain might ooh
okay okay okay let's go all right bud
nice oh that's fine
do executions work on him yeah yes they
do
I'm sorry dude oh they don't work that
well okay I can't hit him on the ground
yeah yeah parent crap
okay yes boom by default would you get I
got a bowl here you have a real Hyrum
sword and a bow nice
I believe that's what the rouhani and
Tory mountain people all right let's see
here
all right three thumbs up okay okay
we'll take it yeah yeah three points
more not my sons
not my son sword the dagger is your son
sir right yeah and you got a skill point
yeah and they got a good kill all right
what today what are gonna get then it's
cool but it's too specific yet to use oh
this one was fun do you throw it very
nice yeah these are kind of fun well so
yeah I just a nice little utility
ability you have to if you guys are just
tuning in we're playing Middle Earth
shadow of war on the Xbox one brought to
you by Duracell the trusted brand for
Xbox gamers we're checking out the skill
tree right now this is Italian and all
the things he can do and then we get
that point but we're also hanging out in
the chat so if you got any questions let
us know and I will read them on GameSpot
and YouTube and twitch
shut up to whoever designed all these
trees and bushes they are like yeah and
they're clutch too because you just
hiding them where I hide wherever you
want yeah where I am and show them what
it's all like dark and midori Gondar the
trees is foliage
so much foliage oh oh come on beating up
on my friend well actually oh wait
they're beating up on whatever sorry
sorry sorry sorry
I got trigger-happy he's like thanks guy
no yeah we needed you happy to help
those wounds will be okay that's cool oh
and that gave me meter one meter that's
cool you get oh uh combo meter for doing
cool stuff that's not good for like
crazy Parker I guess we get a coolness
meter now yeah it's called the boom look
at that yes he did he had a full dope
unit when he rode down that first movie
no he was out of dopamine Ephram CTV
said what's this game about well it's a
sequel to shadow of Mordor it takes
place between the events of The Hobbit
and Lord of the Rings can that work just
Ranger named tallien you want to sum up
what the first he was he was a ranger he
was sacrificed to like bring the soul of
Caliburn bar back into like the bad guy
but instead it went into him so now he
has all these like elf ghost powers uh
he went around and killed a lot of orcs
and Shelley got to the hand of Sauron
and now they were like you know we need
to fight Sauron so we should make our
own ring and then immediately that man
stole their own ring but then she love
took it yep
not sure how she just sort of took it
kind of asked for it any game - it's
fine uh and now we're uh I guess kind of
working for her but also like saving the
realm yeah yeah so that's there we go in
the immediate stopping us yeah right now
we're starting were stopping this siege
someone is under siege finally pounder
because it's false we're at minutes if
it'll not knock on door just watch it
wavy boy isn't gone Dorothy country yeah
nerd cred inject yeah why are we because
sometimes that's cool
yes you know like just based on kills oh
he got he got an army of undead to come
and like win the day yeah sort of deus
ex machina style it's it's fine the
hobbits
they're there for emotional support but
yeah not a lot of muscle to be honest of
course not but they also helped each
other just help the team like they like
I don't know Marion did some stuff to
like kind of Norrish their mission along
uh they did I think was it married this
my crowd they tired with all the thing
you're getting the founder he grabbed it
which had the benefit of making Sauron
think the ring was there and
oh yeah what do you get credit if you
accidentally do something awesome sure
counting what are you guys look at these
cutscenes they're cool
yeah I like I get a good look on their
on their armor defending the gate which
way is the gate the gate is this way oh
it doesn't feel they have so many
worried oh god playing fire literally
okay bye wait what you don't need no you
that's what you build up you don't need
her now you build up the dope meter the
top the top one see once that gets
filled after doing cool stuff okay then
you can do it yeah sorry trigger-happy
you can't beat the way my sword guys
that's been a whole game fighting alone
sorry
sure I'll follow you seeing as I'm
credit Italian and your credit its guard
number one
tarek on YouTube Chet said in the first
game time was really weak and
outnumbered at the start is that the
case here - no like knows right yeah you
see a severe kickin ass yeah I I
definitely had a little trouble in the
beginning because they gave me so many
the things that I was familiar with that
I overestimated all the things but you
get like a lot of things that you're
used to having you get already we just
won this Oh sweetie come take much more
know the seat speed yeah yeah good
you guys go bare North's like oh well if
you want to I really wanted to go to go
fight that thing okay you know what fine
I'll let you have this time next one's
all me damage the scene speech to Vegas
okay okay sounds easy
whoa let's roll out you're on fire I'm
on fire I know all right now go do
that's it that's it how can you just
stay down there there we go
I mean there we go oh I don't pick up
the arrows thank you all right come here
okay okay that's badass
he's my bell hahaha new friend uh yeah
that and boom look I know the beggars
can't be choosers here but if you can
try and kill all them and not damage the
wonderful architecture in this beautiful
city I'll give it a shot
just
I think it's a little too far in no I
got it oh wait nope yeah there we go
I'm sorry that's your brother okay feast
please please see you yelling speech be
nice that's his catchphrase no I don't
want to pity we can't take it I know
look I can't take it with us it's again
war I don't want and the shadow of it
the shadow of war you don't always get
to have it your way
okay bye seeds beasts we had fun
together this time I'm sorry at least
kill him nicely that was it's fine I'm
sure he didn't suffer it's interesting
what it's funny crumble like here's your
mouth Oh double jump what okay I guess
some double jumping parkour show-offs I
see what the dwarves are oh you know
he's like do that to just double jump
breaking the laws of physics whoa till
they find a plant yeah Elliot
going up no going up actually get up I'm
in full seconds wait what
definitely oh I did not take the optimal
route did you know there was a time yep
I screwed up
count it I'm here oh come on hello it
was a bonus mission I guess it's fine
boop boop
nice I don't want to mount you now
because I'm gonna have to kill you
if we don't it's under our control I'm
just saying he doesn't use the Killa
I've already said I guess I gotta have
to kill another Majestics each piece we
have to use you have to use this anger
against other words yes yes channel your
anger I'm sorry I think it's a bug can
you go now I hit him I have you please
dead kidding I can't even tell boom oh
okay there you go CDs oh no they have a
health bar sorry I was out
[Laughter]
so we're playing on the Xbox one so
November 7th we are you guys high for
the Xbox one us yeah yeah what I'm
looking forward to about it uh I got a
4k TV finally yeah future fruit so I
would like to start justifying that for
just with yeah
yeah so well it's got 4k blu-rays and 4k
gaming yeah
upgraded graphics and RAM mm-hmm 1080p
gaming good stuff oh yeah it's not
enough for them to destroy us Oh
mr.white way I Street Oh sad times yeah
actually wait use in this town the gate
suppose they this see fall does it these
relics isn't one of these yeah that's
crazy loading the green place that
salmon for no go by in my yes I mean
it's no does this one fall are we are we
just fighting a losing battle right now
should I not name this town Earl that's
why it cuz it makes it kind of like it
dresses him down a little bit you know
it's sort of a blue-collar siege beast
just a working man that tallien then
kills Jesus bummed yeah sad times this
is look you are justified in being upset
that they're trying to wipe your town
out but what I suggest and it feels
really good is to just go into a group
of them and just take them all out it's
therapy I think it's pretty therapy yeah
I love this sword all right yeah
complete I like that you cuz you
upgraded you had the same weapons in the
first one right you just upgraded them
with runes yeah kind of like new items
yeah alright let's see what we got here
seeing stone complete what else we got
to do oh I like this quest or waiting
yeah oh that's out of reads like that oh
I gotta go I see I gotta go find a UH
where is another one of those towel
towers oh oh whoa you uh you get a
bigger map oh I like to read it all
right uh ooh dark sandals level 18 okay
well maybe ever loved
maybe I don't take that city right now
maybe I can okay oh fast travel Oh
Elliott okay well we haven't unlocked
any other places here a shell of course
she lists yeah oh now I can faster
interesting what we're gonna go to your
new destination I wouldn't stay here
there's so much to do
in minutes you feel that you have here
for a bit all right all right
because we saw two other towers to take
and it looks pretty when we have two of
their missions to do just from that
first tower that we saw I thought where
is it about 45 minutes left in the
stream so you can decide based on that
all right chap what do you guys want to
do let us know in the chat what you want
to see happen and there might be a bit
of a delay okay let's find out check you
guys want to stay in the city or move on
to the next I don't I don't know it's
only three you can it's the next quest
it's the next story quest you can
definitely get there okay but we'll see
we'll see what chat says in the meantime
well chat is deciding oh that's like
kill some general said Georgie Mack over
on your chat is that shows you Mack is
that like captain's but higher-ranking
IV medications come on now how did you
do your thing just go say twice so let
yourself fall a bit and then press a
again oh you can more than double jump I
mean like the first ones a job and that
jump again Billy be singing everything
kill everything yeah so request to kill
some generals and our quest to kill
everything alright we're killing stuff
Oh
treasure
type of targets have left trigger it's
like the battery yeah very nice frost
Reaper said right a dragon Oh we'd love
to
I mean I'd love to it laughs I feel like
that's not available yet I think we're
gonna have to work for that good you
know up great I think we did upgrade the
gym hold X yeah all right all right more
we went from 2 times a 2 percent
lifesteal to 4 and it took three left
gyms so there's a little lost efficiency
and that process happened overboard I
thought you were the master of forging
chocolate
this is him talking to himself well no
they sure know I mean is that to
illustrate for like the audience's
perspective yeah
no they no one else sees them Oh Gollum
well that's cos gums
we welcome guys also you get out the way
bro come on bro I really wonder what
it's like to be Oh
ambushed he's really good at people like
really good this projectile okay
he likes bombs assassin any weaknesses
in ready type anything we don't have
couldn't be any distortions throw stuff
at him hit him with the knives
there you go whoa okay okay maybe guys
maybe get out of the way guys guys guys
come just Amin Oh
- in right trigger yeah and stay down
sorry you forced my hand and you cannot
yeah you gotta get out of the way dude
got a random soldier just just chill you
sir
boom there you go there you go you hear
that Oh a new sword
yeah it's better at 34 this is the sword
from the last game right but it it looks
like it yeah I mean cool I'm pretty sure
this one well that's the one you started
with so now it's yeah more powerful it's
a more skill yeah okay we have why do we
guys want to get crazier is cool but
brutal Oh brutalize oh we can't do it
yet not good damn enough points yeah oh
we do it it's saying you can't the
upgrades for oh you can't get up well
this is good because it builds up so
okay so executions are not hit streets
anymore
no you got a cool meter talk about me
I'll blow that all right now you have
executions go Oh beautiful that forms so
you're heading towards the fast travel
point yeah head explode what oh you just
dreamed no straight through the brain
oh all right double jump air yeah now
we're double jumping in power
well Oh beautiful Olympic medalist right
there I've watched him Lisbon again I
don't remember seeing anyone do that
what do you good long jump like that
they like that's like I guess we stand
so so he wins question from Michael
jolly would it be advisable to play the
last game before playing this game yes
I'm gonna enough story right in terms of
story but also because the first game is
a better really great and so if you want
double the opportunity to like heaven we
have a great time
I don't know that going backwards for
playing this would be as rewarding and
starting with the first two going on
this iPhone that's true mm-hmm okay so
if you're thinking about no girls or do
we really us oh no these are already
these things before you discovered okay
oh oh yes if each tower has its own
stuff to discover you come on you're
around yourself area go on during
artifact Oh missed one this one you
missed one
yeah oh god no you're missing a she love
thing Oh yep Oh you get ya know
sometimes yeah it's like all right we'll
give you this one Oh down Oh
so what other games are you guys playing
right now
all right now we're always the last game
that you were playing destiny to a lot
yes fun mm-hmm I'm right now I'm playing
golf story on the switch I heard that's
a lot of fun it is it is absolutely
charming and they live in great so crazy
that we have two amazing golf games this
year not everybody's going to you yeah
I'm just really into the character
creator on that nice yeah there's a lot
of compared last week to a dead person
what looks bad an animal oh I guess we
found a mission I was looking at earlier
nope why does whole day to mount stuff
is me tapping it what's causing yeah
yeah yeah
use whole day just sprinting on right
into yes it's beautiful
no you haven't tried your it's not a
group big enough yet but you haven't
tried your special yet feel free to
attack me anybody there you go got your
executions up dude try your super l3r 3r
the old gods my shooting present yeah
more Xpress more X and they're dead
[Laughter]
hiding while your guys died yeah but
like not good for survival food
executions up xq sometimes way no oh no
its back up don't were you seeing these
orange yep now he's dead i knew he was
coming and the warp some Jack keeps
talking about the flash they just love
flash they're asking you guys sing flash
and then whoever is monitoring your chat
sang flash with a bunch of dudes
dudududu there we go oh wait this is the
gun Doreen artifact I found your flag
yeah
can you go back to is there like a
minute I'm sure it's gonna be there it
was just the voiceover was already here
is it under Tennessee yeah oh yeah cool
all right yo Oh another stretcher guy
yes
boom are you still interrogating pieces
I mean yeah there are three people down
there too it's there we'll get there
Chad said we can kill whoever we want
yeah that's true we're doing
yeah we're chanting kill everything
another small one always it like so you
gotta get three play Diablo where it's
like you gotta yeah three of each
upgrades it's a nice little got it oh
please oh here we go
dude interrogate Jenna Jenna you got
this are you going he's running from you
if you walk your booth go go go go go
dude you got this just sprint
you guys it was your dude the
information to get out obviously do a
head thing oh I didn't go through the
head that's up there
I love how many more I don't know how
many likes execution animations they
have but I am still seeing new ones and
it's a delight every time oh I know I
know animation had to finish don't blame
me yes yeah oh oh yeah we keep
forgetting about that that glaive which
one hold X for that spear yeah
boom you have to find it you gotta find
some okay sometimes our sticking into
the walls
alright yeah cuz last game blaringing
where we're question from Rio Fudo tangu
said Davis do you guys have any plans to
make a comedy sketch of this game uh
maybe we did we did one for the first
one the first one yeah what'd you guys
do it was oh you know tallying you how
he can you serve his mind so Intel he
was searching in orcs mind for Intel but
I just kept revealing weird personality
quirks about it like that work had like
a stuffed animal and a bunch of other
weird stuff you're leaving out the
dirtier ones you should go watch I'll
check it out we can just rename it
shadow no we can do that just rename it
shadow no you know where they are you oh
really bad at gaining Intel I'm not kind
of like high school it's I'm not finding
out who I was and I wasn't a study I
control you yet but so I'm just not
gonna lay down sir Oh or can you wait
can you jump on it Oh
stealth double saw execute
your tokens always run away yeah they're
doing their whelps or whatever boom
everything's on fire worth it
and isn't okay I'm gonna let this dog do
this thing yeah get them come on there's
a lot of people I don't think I can
reasonably brave to come after me alone
NES treasure yay whoo a red gem just
give it a second guys
here we go yeah Oh No get up get up get
that health count it you got it so we
have about a half hour left in this
stream if you're just tuning in we're
playing Middle Earth shadow of war just
came out today playing on the Xbox one
brought to you by Duracell the trusted
brand for Xbox gamers
we've got Davis and sure to hear from
the warp zone we're cross streaming to
the warp zones YouTube channel we're
also on GameSpot calm we're on
GameSpot's twitch and GameSpot's youtube
so you've got any questions or comments
chime in the chat and we will look at
those might answer them to speak he's a
spear thrower yeah oh this is gonna be
great
you're gonna do fine games great you got
this yeah new skills at your disposal
[Laughter]
identify him yeah he's well he
definitely likes animals piers and
killing and shadow strike makes him
angry and you can you know sell okay you
got this
question and the twitch chat how does
the combat feel compares the first game
Sam or faster seems a little bit out of
you've got a run tactical retreat tax
bill retreat don't worry I you guys are
making you both um everything cuz the
combat was great the first one
everything feels a little bit smoother
it's kind of ironed out yeah just like
there's a lot of quality of life
upgrades to it so that's nice here what
gives me health back do I have anything
you have to drain them just draining
people so you think it starts but in in
the lap like you go into stealth mode
you can just like fine
you can stealth drain it's something
that good okay not good no don't wait
come on
you serious you just like took your time
on the bench oh there you go you got
full arrows time to pick some people off
all right yes so many people now I have
fewer people after me in the of one less
arrow oh that's new
nobody told me about that feature okay
this is where you can hold them here
oh okay jump jump jump to the other roof
you jump
welcome back to pick this up later what
I like to do also this helps me with
mine okay
loneguy oh yeah Nicholas and your chat
said what's the favorite sketch that
you've done that's a hard question yeah
maybe recently which of my 300 babies
well recently this year
yeah how about this year I mean I really
like tune the spoil the game of Thrones
spoilers sketch cuz I bet do that John
wick scene oh yeah we did like a sketch
about trying to like not watching Game
of Thrones oh my god on the mouth airs
and trying to avoid spoilers at work and
then it ended be like stay off the
internet forever - yeah you got a
choreographer yeah because we did like a
John wick action sequence so cool and so
yeah we have to do some air action work
and it's not currently in my place do I
have this feel that I get life back my
stealth kill so would you believe that's
a viable excuse for why did why did
right there
sure Lionheart Queen said I love
crushing their skulls in this game
totally very satisfying dude you're just
gonna have to you got to shoot him guys
shoot him that's how we do it head shots
three head shots one
and you're out what can we call it a
draw
you can't okay Exley's ah yeah now what
are you gonna do follow you do you see
on the map
this feels like you're like 5 star
wanted level in Grand Theft Auto this is
this is the there's just so many people
trying to kill you ok you see I'm trying
get any arrows some I don't I see arrows
being shot at you does that does that
help does that care abort org or
whatever you are go away he'll do you
not get any of it back if you know you
got to get the full shoot the barrels
[ __ ] it sorry you shoot the barrels see
the barrel suit the brown suit barrel I
do not oh my god these guys aren't hard
there's so many of them there's a lot
the grunts are finding it's the care go
and the other do this Oh kill that guy
he's nice it alone
you got it you got it
whoo I'm a big help
he actually was like oh thank you thank
you for your just double stealth kill
there cuz ice house I'm Titan dude oh
okay
both no one sees you then go over here
is because I think I see oh no it's this
way
arrows over there the girls intense come
on baby
I'm gonna kill all these people there
you go let me only see the Beast well I
think you should know that you do have
arrows I think you should try to lure
them to those barrels though get one big
explosion
Oh dunzo for you here we go
I'm Justin in the herd yes so we're
playing this on the xbox one you do get
your hands on an Xbox one X what games
do you want to check out on it are you
most looking forward to Haru will you be
playing this playing some Assassin's
Creed origin when does it come out
number seven okay
I will definitely I actually have like
five xbox one games I think a little
collection and some other stuff so go
back and do those yeah
elephants yeah Trey SAS escrito origins
was a good one despite it's like gonna
be a plenty of back catalog exclusives
are king of yeah that's true use the
back and play oh yeah with their
backwards compatibility oh nice why want
is health like Jim well you can get this
guy's help
that was close we're mounting a slow oh
he was this high that guy was hiding
behind the pillar
I know these these people are not if
they were a little bit smarter about
like in wanting their other friends can
move as well they all really do some
damage to me
I think no spear spear thrower yeah
you're so almost full of your meter yeah
so like then you can jump into the group
of people and just go to town oh yeah
what once you get that back up yeah yeah
lure them all in and then you can just
get them all get all their attention
here we go I have like oh should I go
back to the roof and get some those
items have enough to forge a second gym
yes you do
all right before you know what I'm gonna
be stealing 6% in life okay someone saw
you whatever man
I'm not even worried right now I have
confidence I previously didn't have oh
hi how are you doing by this moment
right mm not oh that's that's cool when
I'm ready to like start farming some
some items we haven't talked about the
Nemesis system yet so what do you think
of the Nemesis system in the first game
and have you noticed any improvement yet
I didn't know it's still early on I mean
I really liked it in the first one I
think it really that was cool uh gave
like all of these NPCs like real
character and really felt like you had
stakes especially like meeting like the
first guy that kills you again and stuff
like that it's oh you have elven rage
but yeah but so I'm assuming that
they've expanded it
like I'm assuming it's gonna be really
good
yeah what to meet all those guys I'm
gonna use it when I know I know you
gotta wait for the for the captains to
come just I'm eagerly anticipating
[Laughter]
nobody had to kill Earl it's just like
with one fire from Earl I could this
entire group is done wait so is pearl
who's Earl now see Jesus yeah he's over
you wanted to be returned the team
changed I win but ok ok everybody just
died execution
you're dead go your dad your dad your
dad one more guidance oh your chats
making me hungry they keep talking about
chicken nuggets can't talk about you
guys
you're fine you're fine but I need more
health grab that go to the rooftops this
used to be lonely guys up there oh no
you got this did you get it and run by
he runs a lot faster now though that's
okay there we go
don't three oh just in time and run oh
whoa I got ya ooh this is one of the
bosses is chairman Rangel people and
start this is he yeah go to the other
SUV get him to follow you to the other
boss oh that's during your help you miss
yeah bye
well don't go too fast you know just run
calculate yeah one Canada okay it's
coming we're playing shadow of war on
the Xbox one we have about 15 minutes
left in the stream and we're gonna kill
two of these guys at once we're just
we're setting it up we got this here
here we go attract him there's a third
captain okay the other guy following you
run dude oh my god there's so many orcs
all right we're doing it make it happen
you might not be affected by arrows dude
[Music]
[Applause]
take us home that's all right that was
unexpected shadows war more like Oh
[Laughter]
everybody's stronger now because they
all got to be part of it yeah they're
learning a little bit more each time
oh that means that's oh yeah captain oh
man okay
all right so we have about 13 minutes
left chat let us know what you want to
see in these next all right
I'll see what you guys want to see next
clue category theory this is there oh
boy
search the area for hope there is no
that's the wrong guy
whoa you I guess he doesn't like flies
can you stop filming
whoa okay there he is he's the guy that
I can take him I got that's the guy
who's fighting yeah you're just gonna
you're gonna repeat my mistakes
yo myself can you can you die by itself
no I didn't use me in a selfie but Shawn
vigilant against self vigilant does not
mean immune immune to self excuses yes
okay Allison wants to see wreaths
nazgul and dragons we would - yes we're
still very early on it or get intel on
that guy actually give me well on that
get over there she loved you love sure
that oh thanks
mark says go after the school lover dude
I will I will
he's just
if I you met yeah yes it's not enough
that you're a killer of ghouls and you
don't comment back when somebody
messages you in facebook I see that you
read the message yeah oh okay
where is he that dude I don't know we're
gonna find out so we must oh well yeah
well he's alone I'm gonna also really
likes Mad Max I don't know if you he's a
big fan there's a drag I see it I just
swung into it it can climb up something
this is make things more difficult than
they were
one centimeter no I know I'm trying to
oh yeah baby
No
by no clog the torture is here what does
this mean humiliation okay wait I'm not
sure what happened the guys so close I
know I'm gonna oh now I'm going after
rare gear just very real quick let's
take a look at it what you get the lure
of it oh I'm sorry
go back into it okay fine why not you
know what I still got a guy who captured
okay I am killing this guy he's running
and falling off a cliff is he also a
great at jumping from hilarious distance
isn't it
you gotta bolt off something dude I got
it ah he's your assassin kill on him no
no he's gonna keep running you guys and
I screwed up do it use your pleasure
bye-bye you dead nice finish kill him
watch out for it maybe people around you
yeah you're gonna trade in the cloak
your wife made you just for some speck
hey we'll trade in a sword that means
something to us for like three points
yeah has like significance to the
character and this game you're like yeah
I found off yeah okay ooh arrows
guys hi Oh see look nice and easy 5v1
is this bread and butter oh nice message
from amar and your chat the warp zone I
love you all so so much thank you
[Music]
Shaymin I'll send love your channel
thanks Janet all right
yes good call there you go yeah all
right yeah you don't put that Nicole
Klein I mean I do yeah
um know if the new dagger the handle
clashes with the color scheme of SC is
that enough to get rid of it
maybe well it depends on whether you
care about filling the cloak let's see
whoo all right that's cool all right
okay that's really cool yep
select new objective I think we might
have finished all the things in here
we gotta touch them mister back button
wait complete complete yeah hey yep all
right so we'll go see what the next area
looks like and that'll probably take us
out yep pretty much we have five minutes
all right get a peek at this new area
let's do it five minutes left in the
streamer playing Miller its shadow of
war are you gonna be playing more of
this game oh yeah yeah oh yeah how does
it compare to the last game for you now
that you've played for a little bit now
a couple hours it looks like they've
just upgraded a lot and fixed a lot of
minor inconveniences it existed in zone
yeah yeah I'm curious what base building
will look like is that that'll be uh
that's fairly big part of the game so Oh
building your like castle yeah each
place yeah mm-hmm I want a cave troll
friend I'm sure and we don't have to
kill to kill our own guys that we
capture for the sake of this moment
we'll call roll you're gonna call girl
and call the kid for girl okay
armies it okay guys oh look at there's
like the environments are already that's
a covariant yeah I mean it's already so
much more like the map was it was like
pretty big in the first one but not like
huge
it was pretty open yeah this this has so
many like so much variety when they give
you like
ways to traverse it even faster yeah
whoa I never figured out how to take
those guys out well oh he's Earl maybe
yeah not our fault or you maybe hangers
em yeah looks like he's fighting them we
can just sort of avoid this fight so one
more question what are your favorite
Xbox games of all time so Oh
halo probably a low or halo too but I
love all the hills yeah like three has
so my favorite and some of my favorite
parts in it
hey looks really cool and I really did
you try halo wars - oh my hellos do with
me I loved really as you can see not a
strange guy it's daddy's stuff so I have
a hard time playing all trashy games
because I just don't have a mind for it
but I love it oh no I got the wrong guy
I did I'm not going to get through this
okay
how do you tackle uh you sprint and then
soon you hold it right Brett enough to
backwards
oh okay okay excuse or get off this one
platform by whole day after you Lana I
think you can continue your but you have
to be in your elven speed mafia who also
83 just now just the tower is not the
enemies oh really
yeah it's just a misleading number then
we got a drain someone quick oh there we
go there is who's the finger with okay
bushes yeah get him get him
you oh thank you for doing yeah I
everybody they got poison to no boy oh
boy oh boy how do you get rid of it oh
it's gone well cool some of the enemies
though they said are like one shot a
bowl by poison mmm you're right
alright we are just about finished with
the stream what do you want to end on
I'll go kill a sick rolls yeah where are
they still hanging out over there see if
they're far away we might as well
oh shoot the guy on top yay I'm so
thankful that he's gonna hug you okay
okay thank you guys so much for watching
our stream check out the warp zone on
YouTube where can they follow you guys
on twitter at warp zone tweets instagram
warp zone grams or our personals that i
guess are right down the street
right down there yeah that's mine yep
and of course you know our channel is
futures yep lots of fun Sanchez over on
the warp zone
YouTube page check out GameSpot for all
things shadow 4 and thanks for joining
us and thanks to Doris L for sponsoring
the stream today see you guys later bye
[Applause]
you